are the other islands i quite liked your
um biking video oh yeah oh yeah if
you're able to go i mean it's a bit out
of the way from tokyo but yeah like
i'm not gonna do it yeah
it looks cool it was it was like [ __ ]
beautiful we somehow like lucked out on
that day
so perfect it was october as well i
think yeah yeah
october yeah it was like october
the perfect kind of like all right
because when you're going in july it's
it's horrible yeah it's just disgusting
oh you're going in july be
careful the heat of the humidity i grew
up in hawaii i've been in the
philippines in july so it's okay it'll
be all right it's it's gross yeah it's
disgusting the cycling was perfect it
was like nice clear like low humidity
and it was just great i mean it's kind
of stressful because you want to focus
more on just cycling but when you're
filming and it was just us three and two
other guys so we're just trying to get
this thing yeah to look and sound good
yeah so you're constantly stopping like
is it are the camera's okay are the
gopro is okay yeah just change batteries
hey i need batteries yeah so you do this
cycling thing that should be down in
like six hours but it takes like 12.
yeah yeah everything is doubled when
you're filming yeah so i'm sure i mean
you do a bunch of stuff with uh offline
tv right yeah so i'm sure stuff is would
be fun if you could just do it off
camera yeah but it's like okay we've got
to redo that again okay let's check it
out they do a pretty good job of like
setting up um
offline tv is very hands off for like uh
when you're in the like they handle a
lot of it yeah oh yeah we kind of do
most of it yeah
yeah it's like a complete like i do
everything for myself channel and all
that yeah and i know it's well it's
cause like it was like especially in
japan uh when we first started trash
taste like the influencer and content
creator like infrastructure just wasn't
there so even if you wanted to hire a
specialist in x y or z to help us make
content it was so hard you just you just
couldn't find it for like for like for
longest time whereas in la it seems like
you guys are able to just get
specialists for like any area and if
they did exist then they were most
likely just like only japanese speaking
only understand the japanese content
creator side of things which is just
completely different to the [ __ ] we do
yeah yeah right so it's like just trying
to explain that to them being like no
we're not going to do it the japanese
way yeah we're going to do it the the
non-japanese way they're just like what
do you mean yeah is there a difference
it's like impossible finding some type
of people that we want to do certain
things yeah because they just don't
exist in japan yeah cause you need
somebody speaks english happens to be in
japan already and is doing that and then
is available to do it yeah yeah like all
right like which is like nobody yeah
right now yeah there's no one yeah maybe
when the country opens up a little bit
it'll be a little easier yeah so so like
for the cycling video it was a lot of it
was just like guesswork by us and it was
like a [ __ ] miracle i think it just
miraculously happened to be something
that was cohesive yeah yeah
yeah
thank god how was the youtube
over there do they do a lot there's one
youtuber i really like over there his
name is sushi ramen yeah because he's
just a japanese version of you
yeah he's [ __ ] awesome yeah um i
don't know i don't watch a whole lot of
japanese youtubers but like i'd say
sushi ram is probably the most
interesting yeah yeah yeah he's
definitely the most interesting yeah a
lot of the japanese stuff is just like
they're trying to rip off japanese tv
yeah yeah it's really not good
thumbnails are [ __ ] awful yeah yeah
their thumbnail game in japan
but like who else can you compete with
because the the japanese market is so
isolated yeah like they they progress
through youtube trends completely
different from the rest of the world
yeah so when you watch it it's so like
bizarre seeing this completely like
singularity yeah it's really interesting
yeah i mean a lot of japanese people if
they speak english they're like oh i'm
just gonna do english because
it makes way more sense yeah yeah
exactly of course it's yeah it's kind of
it's interesting yeah i mean like the
creator like field or just the creator
community there it's like pretty small
especially compared to somewhere like
l.a but i mean it's slowly growing yeah
slowly growing slowly yeah slow there's
a decent amount of english channels
doing videos yeah i'm sure if you've
seen like any you've already seen a
bunch i don't know yeah probably yeah
i mean the jay vlogging scene is coming
back right yeah but i mean everyone
because [ __ ] felix moved down started
making j vlogs right that's that's this
is what happens
and then all the jvloggers came out of
their bunkers they're like we can make
jvlogs again okay
it's good though like it's like when did
when did you move to la again like four
years ago four years ago i'm like that
yeah how are you finding it like it's
all right
now this city [ __ ] sucks this is ass
that's what everyone says yeah yeah but
i can't leave the people i can't believe
the
like i convinced like my friends from
high school to move here right um
and like and they're like what have you
done what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
yeah i'm broke my rent is too high and
everything's broken it's ass i'm trying
to like explore more of it um
because i i'd like to know where i am
yeah um so i've been going around doing
more [ __ ] um like riding
like
uh like bird scooters as much as i can
around areas yeah yeah bikes and stuff
yeah yeah yeah so it's i think the
problem is just like la is just not
built for like scooters and bikes no
it's both for the car it's beautiful
cars right because i've been to like
european cities where i've tried out the
scooters yeah just
and it's more useful than cars involved
so
like
it's it's it's hard because i i when i
like to explore places i like to like
walk places yeah la is just
walking yeah like everywhere else as a
city it's like oh the downtown is the
cool place but like downtown ali is like
just terrifying do anything there it's
not even fun like you're not even
risking it for a benefit it's just bad
yeah so before like this trip i pretty
much have only been to like the downtown
side of la because that was where like
anime expo is so we would only have like
a few days around anime expo so the only
places to explore is basically like
little tokyo and downtown l.a
and it was
i think everyone has a different
experience and has a different story
with shitty things that have happened in
downtown people yeah downtown it's
awesome yeah it's it's like this is the
best country uh your best town ever if
you wanna like people watch yeah because
like there's just the strangest people
existing yeah yeah l.a and new york are
like the topic
portland also has some good [ __ ] yeah
portland has some crazy [ __ ] happening
maybe more than downtown l.a why i don't
know um i've been in portland once and
like walking on the street
like i was there for like one day and i
got like voodoo donuts which is like a
famous donut place in la and this like
dude walks up to me and he's like can i
have that and i was like eating this it
was called [ __ ] and balls and it was a
donut shaped like a dick and balls
and i was like you know what i'm done
with it yeah you can have it and like
it's in the napkin and it's like in a
rapper and he's like oh thanks and he
[ __ ] grabbed it by the shaft
and i took it out of my hand it was
crazy oh dude my friend my friend just
started gobbling on the walls yeah my
friend gabe lives in portland and he
said he
he had this great story he went like on
the train
right
this like homeless person came up to him
and he was like hello can
the the guy said hi can i shake your
hand
and my friend was like
usually just doesn't shake hands with
random people but the whole train looked
at him yeah everyone was looking at him
he's like okay i gotta kind of do this
or else i'm an [ __ ] and he's like
city like slow motion saw the hand
coming and then he shaked it and the guy
said i have aids
[Music]
he is
what did he say after that apparently
they talked to the end of the thing like
about like how he has aids a little bit
yeah
but just his life
holy [ __ ] quite an okay conversation
yeah yeah america is scary america's
weird yeah yeah i had something similar
happened to me on the uk tube though
yeah oh yeah yeah i had like uh the sort
of uk metro in london i i went on
because i was going uh somewhere i think
i was heading to your place
maybe or somewhere in london but some
homeless dude came up to me and he was
like uh excuse me sir and then he pulls
his shirt up and there's just like a
giant [ __ ] laceration like this big
and he's just bleeding from it and he's
like i just got stabbed
and uh i need hospital funds
and i'm like
what the [ __ ]
and so so like you know and again same
situation everyone in the tube is
looking at me and i'm like well i can't
say no i can't say no so i just gave him
like a one pound yeah that's what it is
i got just stuff it is a pound
hospital funds we're in the [ __ ] uk
yeah what are you talking about yeah yes
yeah right so i just like i gave it to
him and then he's like thank you and
then i thought about i'm like
isn't it free yeah in the uk yeah yeah i
mean luckily i didn't give him like a
tape i mean he deserved it but he was
like
i could see it was like clearly not like
makeup it was like full on he got
stabbed why was he on the tube that's
what i want to know
if you get stabbed first thing you do
start going to ask him for money
what is this
i was like i was expecting that [ __ ] in
america not the uk i'm just conditioned
in the uk whenever anyone like talks to
me like no yeah
yeah yeah because like if someone starts
talking to you in the uk something's
gone wrong yeah you just said yeah yeah
you say like no
it's like in japan when someone starts
talking to you it's like i'm in trouble
normally yes yeah normally yes yeah
normally you have [ __ ] up yeah yeah
yeah yeah they should leave you alone
that's the whole country's design
yeah
yeah especially in london as well
because i remember like when i first
moved to london uh i was like you know
trying to be really polite i was on the
tube i was like letting people you know
letting people go in front of me if they
needed to go or something and like
within a month of moving to london i was
like [ __ ] pushing kids out the way if
someone if someone like stood on like
the left side of like the [ __ ]
escalator i i think i'd put out a hit on
them you know because in england if you
stand you always have to stand on the
right side of the escalator always
remember that and it's like i actually
like messed up because in japan it's
like left side right and i remember
standing on the left side in london when
i went back this time and i i didn't i
forgot and someone like tried to like
[ __ ] bust past me right i felt i felt
like the shame man i felt the shame
i betrayed myself man in tokyo it's the
left but in osaka it's the right is that
yeah yeah
in west japan you stand on the right
side but in east japan you stand on the
left side i don't know why
it doesn't make any sense called grids
are different
yeah maybe yeah it's gotta right
[Laughter]